hey everybody welcome back see a guru on
today's episode is kind of special
as you might notice it's a special
Christmas episode that I wanted to do so
in the last part of this video I'll get
into some Christmas decorations and
lighting and stuff like that around
Jaeger horn since I figured I wanted to
try something like that with one of my
maps just take the map as it is and just
add Christmas decorations to it and then
see how it changes its look because it's
sort of interesting how and planet
coaster with the way that you sort of
build things there's always a certain
look to a place whereas in a real theme
park things often kind of change during
the seasons depending on how you
decorate everything so I just wanted to
try and mess around with that idea a
little bit and figure it since Jaeger
horn is already in Alpine Park and has
this very wooden rustic style to it I
think it would be the best of my
projects to dress up in a bit of a
Christmas way in any case in the first
part of this video I actually won't be
working on that quite yet what I wanted
to do is work on the queue specifically
I'll be spending most of my time on
these two little roof covers that are
going over the first part of the queue
with all of them this sort of small
cattle pens here and that's really just
about it looking back at this episode I
ended up spending a lot of time just
making these very simple roofs because
I'm making everything myself and adding
all of the tiny little scenery items
together to make these roofs look unique
and like nothing that's in the game
itself but that basically ended up being
a very time-consuming process but I
think there's there's some interesting
takeaways from it although generally I'm
really staying in this style of the rest
of the build so this again is going to
be in that Alpine Swiss Chalet sort of
style with mostly wood work
but quite a bit of detailing added to
that as well and for one I am finally
using some of the new spooky sets wooden
pillars that we have which I'm actually
really glad that way you finally got
these because a lot of those spooky
updates stuff has very Victorian feel to
it
the Swiss Chalet style in general is
from around the 1900s when it was really
popular and when you can find a lot of
old traditional buildings from it so the
Victorian style suits it quite a bit and
there's a lot of Victorian elements in
it very often so I'm actually really
glad with how versatile the spookie pack
update was in terms of adding all of
these little Victorian scenery details
that you can pretty much add into any
build the same to be honest I think kind
of goes for the adventure updates I know
I haven't talked about this that much
but I really loved the new pieces in the
adventure updates and it's just another
another thing where even though it's
it's strictly for adventure supposedly
there are so many different uses for the
pretty objects in there since there's a
lot of more versatile scenery items in
there and everything is recoverable so
I'm really happy with how versatile the
dlcs have become in general and that you
can really use them for much more than
what they promised in any case to catch
up with the build a little bit so we
just have these two very simple roof
covers that cover the cattle pens here
and I just wanted to get a basic
structure in it's not a complicated room
for anything just straights very simple
and then just dress it up with some
details now this was a little bit
inspired actually no actually for her he
inspired by the cue of symbolic ax in
the ethylene which kinda similarly I
think is also for space reasons because
symbolic ER has a bit of a space problem
in that it is a dark right in the middle
of a park and if you look at large dark
rides in Disney or many other parks
they're usually toward the edge of a
park because that you need a lot of
space for a dark ride but in the
efteling it's the sensory attraction so
it's right in the castle in the middle
of the park but that means that it ends
up using a lot of space for the dark
ride itself and there's not a lot of
space left for the queue so I think
symbolic AHA's this sort of very compact
cattle pen queue
simply because there wasn't any room for
anything larger and I have a bit of a
similar issue here since I sort of
worked myself up to the edge of the park
here and I already sort of established
some borders
or the Jaeger horn park just to force
myself to make this very compact and
force myself to weave everything into
each other and use the space efficiently
because I wanted this to be that compact
in order to feel a bit more realistic I
think especially if you have a write
like this having it being very spread
out wouldn't be as realistic as making
maximum use of space but in the end I
did sort of work myself into a corner
with the cube here so there wasn't
really much that I could do except for
just play some buildings over here I'm
definitely gonna dress it up later with
a lot of foliage the idea is that these
buildings are sort of standing in the
middle of the forest and all the trees
should definitely spruce this up at some
point in the future although that said
I'm now starting work on the second
building the second roof and this is
also one of the reasons why it took a
lot of time because I basically made
them both nearly from scratch because
even though they're very similar they
have the same look and almost the same
dimensions they're not quite the same
because the second one is longer and a
little bit narrower so I have to make
most of the things from scratch over
here again just to make sure that
everything fits even though the roof
itself of course was copied but yeah
this one this second one is pretty
important because it actually has a
pretty good sight line I just wanted
some sort of path interaction with the
view that you have of the coaster over
here scenes right in front of this this
roof there's a little Valley and the
coaster dips underneath the bridge which
gives a pretty nice view from this path
and also in the distance behind that
little valley if you're standing
underneath this roof you'll be able to
see the station and the bridge and just
a coaster in general it's kind of hard
to explain what it looks like but I'll
end this video with a shot directly from
underneath the roof of the queue so you
can kind of get an idea of what you a
good Horne is gonna look like when
you're standing inside the cube because
for me it's it's one of my favorite if
not my favorite views of the coaster
because you get all the most important
elements of the coaster all
of you you've got the bridges in the
front you've got the station building
you've got the church which is the big
weenie on top of the mountain very much
in the distance right over the station
building in the bridges and you can even
see parts of the lift Hill and a bunch
of tangled mess of tracks so I think
it's it's one of the best views to have
in the park in general and just the view
that I wanted to have for the queue as
well I think actually I think I actually
showed it for a split second there
though I'm not entirely sure but yeah
these are basically the buildings so
they are now done with the little detail
touches just being those those cables on
the side with the woodwork and the
wooden carving detailing and of course a
bunch of spires every who had because
that makes everything look a little bit
nicer I tried using the adventure items
for these spires at first but they're a
little bit too large and I still think
the Christmas baubles have the best
texture and the best very narrow pointy
shape to them to build these spires out
of so I think I will be sticking to
those especially for this project but
maybe at some point in the future some
of the adventure stuff could be used for
some larger spires or something like
that I don't know
but for now I'm sticking with the
Christmas stuff because it just it just
works really well and also the cable
because that's like the most narrow
object anyway I wanted to talk about
ferns a little bit because you can see
me place a couple ferns over here and to
be honest the ferns are really one of my
favorite editions of the adventure
updates because they're one of these
pieces of foliage which like I kind of
said up there somewhere early in the
video it's something which is a lot more
versatile than just the theme that it's
meant to be for so even though there are
tropical ferns I think they work out
quite well in any kind of climates and
when you've got forests like this in
mountains even in alpine areas in Europe
there are quite a lot of ferns and it's
one of this sort of underbrush foliage
type at that planet coaster didn't have
so much one of the things that I was
sort of missing is that everything looks
very fancy but you don't have a lot of
foliage
sort of grows randomly more or less
wheat sometimes you just want to have
weeds here in it here and there and some
of the new plants but also those ferns
work out really well for that sort of
stuff because a lot of the times if
you've got some sort of some sort of
ground in in a forest or something like
that there's quite a bit of ferns and
other kinds of underbrush like that and
I'm just really happy that we finally
have some ferns in the game and that
they they manage to work quite well even
outside of a tropical setting so the
textures just the fact that they've been
added at all this is one of the things
that I'm most happy with in the
adventure updates and you're probably at
some point see me go back in a lot of my
projects and just add ferns everywhere
and similar types of plants because it's
just a little bit of variety that I've
been missing kind of so far anyway until
the last billing thing if this episode
which is going to be the final part of
the queue the one thing of the queue
which I didn't finish yet is the sort of
zigzag little path where other it's just
gonna be foliage around its but there
are no roofs or anything and I guess I
might get to that in the next episode
but it's not it's not going to be quite
as difficult to do or quite as
time-consuming and I thought through
this episode I just want to focus on
finishing the building aspects and also
finishing the exterior of the station
building because even though the station
building itself is already quite
finished there's this this part of the
queue which sticks out like a sore thumb
when it was unfinished so I just really
wanted to add some railings here add
some walls here and make it all look
clean and nice so that's what we're
getting to here also what's really happy
that we now have is the barriers that we
can stop people with which I'm gonna be
using in a second
not quite yet but it's something that I
was secretly hoping for because as you
might notice I've got two supports right
in the middle of the path which surely
people would walk straight through but
I'm hoping by placing these barriers
over here yep there we go
that
for one I can stop people from walking
into the pillars but also you can kind
of use them to barrier of some parts of
the queue and use those to play some
scenery because in in real life very
often in queues especially especially my
favorite queues you have some random
little scenery elements like this
everywhere in some pottery some barrels
some some chests crates all that sort of
stuff and it's kind of hard to add this
directly into the queue and planet
coaster because people will walk through
it if you place it on the path but I
think with just a few of those barriers
which even still that's nothing unheard
of sometimes you'll have some ropes or
something around silly scenery elements
in theme parks and I think with those
barriers at least we should be able to
stop people from walking straight into
them I have to be very honest though I
didn't test it yet so I I'm actually
kind of banking on the fact that this is
gonna work but it it should I think so
one of the very last things is adding a
bunch of foliage around here I was very
careful with what kind of trees I wanted
because I wanted some trees in front of
them in front of the station but I
wanted some selected parts of the
station to still be visible so was a bit
of a puzzle of what kind of tree would
work out best in what position to keep
most of the station view in text in any
case we're moving on to the Christmas
part of this video because that was more
or less it for the queue so now I placed
a Christmas tree after a long time of
trying to figure out where I could even
place a Christmas tree I didn't even
place it on the path because there's no
like good square at the moments to place
it on that's like completely finished so
I decided to add it in the sort of
center point right in front of the
station
right between the coaster tracks which
doesn't quite make it a traditional sort
of Christmas tree but I think in the
context it works out quite well
especially I guess with the presents
underneath it and in signaling that this
is the big Christmas tree even though
it's not on the path but yeah I figured
that was just my best shot here and for
the rest of this I wanted to try and lay
down all of these lights alongside the
building mostly just following the roof
lines of the station
and also some of the other buildings but
also doing some other Christmas lights
you know just crank up that electricity
bill here and put up some lights
alongside the windows as well
and some of the pillars just in general
I was looking to place them in such a
way that the general contours of the
buildings would be most recognizable so
that even if everything else falls away
and it's completely pitch black and you
can only see the lights that you can
still tell by the shape of the lights
that this is the station or that another
building is the church on top of the
mountain so that was basically sort of
my idea here to be honest I'm kind of
out of my field of expertise here
because I don't know anything about
placing Christmas lights this is just
what I judged from pictures and such
would be the best way to go forward with
this and help it's just it's just
Christmas right lights what am i what am
I talking about this is no just no
rocket science you're just placing
lights everywhere where it kind of looks
cool I shouldn't I shouldn't try to be
pretentious and make myself sound better
than I do I just I just kind of put up
some music and was like let's play some
Christmas lights everywhere so this is
one of my favorite parts actually
because the the church looks pretty cool
with Christmas lights I'm not sure how
acceptable it is that I'm putting all of
these lines of lights everywhere or just
the fact that I'm building a church
building in general in a theme park but
I think it works out quite well works
out too well not to do it so looks very
cozy and very Christmassy and again I
sort of followed the general outline of
the most important parts of the building
to make sure that it would be
recognizable that this is the church
building and its spire I said well how
is the battlements over here I'm not
sure if anybody has ever placed
Christmas lights over that sort of stuff
but no the buttresses there we go not
sure if anybody actually placed any
Christmas lights ever on buttresses but
it looks pretty cool actually oh yeah
and the bridge as well since that's a
pretty major part of this build as well
now that the lights were done I wanted
to put some of these little Christmas
actually what I'm not sure what you
would call these but I figured I
actually actually got this idea when I
was in Disney see because Disney see
actually did this as well with a few
buildings and most notably the Scrooge
McDuck sort of gift shop which is just
in general a really cool building has a
lot of these on its and I completely
don't know the English word but in any
case these little Christmas hedge
looking things kind of like mistletoe is
except they're not round although I also
put up a few mistletoes there's even one
in the shape of a star which is pretty
cool and finally there's just a little
bit of lighting because I'm gonna be
taking night shots but so far I haven't
actually done anything in nights in
Jaeger horn so I had to sort of touch up
the lighting a little bit this is also
just gonna be temporary because it's not
really that great lighting I just try to
light it up well for the pictures and
videos that I wanted to take but yeah
thank you guys for watching and I hope
to see you guys next time in Jaeger horn
and Merry Christmas everybody
[Music]
[Music]